ce qui est très intéressant pour nous
c'est que nous opérons en règle générale
par corrélation nous regardons et nous
comparons ce que nous trouvons sur
différents
théâtres et bien sûr un des sujets les
plus importants du moment c'est celui de
la menace posée par le groupe Ansar
communéement appeléi en mer
Rouge car a longuement publié sur les
dynamiques de la
région et ce que nous observons est ce
que nous essayons de caractériser ce
sont les circuits d'approvisionnement
par l'Iran mais aussi autonome par les
housi en matériel car a énormément
documenté d'armes de munitions de
composants d'engin exposif improvisé et
de drone en provenance d'Iran au Yémen
ou saisi au
Yémen ce qu'il faut noter tout de même
c'est que ansarallah et les hi
s'appuyent sur un arsenal préexistant
l'arsenal yeménite préexistant et des
capacités de production domestique on
sait par exemple et on a beaucoup
documenter des mines et des engins
explosif improvisés produits en quantité
industriell parce que les pouvaient
s'appuyer sur des capacité de de
manufacture domestique